pour moi mon fils il vaut toute ma vie
alors on vit pourquoi alors
2022 le père de William un garçon de 10
ans qui souffre d'une grave maladie
dégénérative de l'oeil la morose
congénitale de Laber l'ancien écrit du
cœur
soit l'état accepte de payer à son fils
un traitement médical extrêmement
coûteux le luxe turna où il va
éventuellement devenir complètement
aveugle on ne peut pas mettre un prix là
pour
l'autonomie et la l'indépendance et la
liberté d'un enfant c'est il mérite
un an plus tard la famille Kerala
obtenue gain de cause l'état rembourse
maintenant le luxurenant et William est
le premier petit québécois a bénéficié
de cette thérapie de pointe il est
nerveux il le ment il demande pas mais
quand même il est il est mais il est
prêt les attentes de la famille sont
réalistes le traitement devrait stopper
net la progression de la maladie et si
tout va bien le garçon va regagner une
partie de la vision qu'il a déjà perdue
j'espère que
mon vision va être plus que
prix banque maintenant et mais ça c'est
comme chose comme c'est comme un bonus
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'avec un coup de près deux
millions de dollars par patient le luxe
tournant et l'un des traitements les
plus chers au monde mais c'est aussi
l'exemple parfait de ce que la médecine
moderne permet d'accomplir dans ce
cas-ci vaincre une maladie héréditaire
pas seulement la contrôler quand j'ai
fait ma ou ma résidence on nous disait
que c'était des maladies intraitables
incurables mais maintenant on peut dire
que on en a finalement une qui est très
tard alors je pense ça donne beaucoup
d'espoir l'opération va durer trois
heures deux experts vont se relayer pour
réaliser une vie traitectomie une
intervention qui permet de retirer les
gens défectueux qui se trouvent dans les
photos récepteurs de l'oeil des William
ce qui rend la chirurgie délicate c'est
que premièrement c'est une chirurgie
avec des gestes très délicats on peut
déposer le médicament sous une couche
très très fine de rétine de cellules
rétiniennes et de plus c'est une
chirurgie chez un jeune enfant
maintenant on va introduire le luxure
Nord ce produit contient des gênes en
pleine santé qui baignent dans une
solution remplie de virus c'est un virus
inactivé qu'on appelle il y a pas la
capacité de transmettre des maladies
mais il y a la capacité de transmettre
les gènes au patients qui portera de
cette maladie spécifique de la ré et
comme ça à partir d'aujourd'hui dans
cette œil il n'y a plus sa maladie
corriger des mutations génétiques
vaincre le cécité redonner la vue à des
enfants c'est un petit peu de la
science-fiction on dirait même pour vous
je n'aime pas de dire que c'est la
science-fiction c'est c'est pour donner
une idée des comment on a évolué
au début on commence
imaginez si un jour il y a quelque chose
aujourd'hui c'est vrai c'est plus la
science-fiction
pour l'équipe soignante c'est longuement
préparé pour cette première médicale
l'intervention est un succès dans
quelques semaines on la répétera cette
fois-ci pour le gauche du jeune William
la bonne chose c'est la progression de
la maladie est terminée on laisse par
bien et c'est ce que la science a prouvé
et c'est sûr que on va continuer à
suivre William tout au courant de son de
sa croissance et on espère bien être
témoin de cette réalité là on évalue
qu'une trentaine de jeunes Québécois
pourrait éventuellement profiter d'un
traitement avec le Luxus tournant
c'est normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal